la parole pour le groupe est républicain
et tam suffit de cocher
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
premier ministre
notre pays est en guerre nous a semblé
au voter l'état d'urgence dans un esprit
de concorde nationale
dans ce contexte la préfecture de police
de paris a interdit dimanche 29 novembre
une manifestation vos discours martiaux
et ceux du président de la république se
succèdent mais que constatons nous la
manifestation interdite a eu lieu des
voyous d'extrême gauche cagoulés ou
masqués ont pu se réunir et infiltré
cette manifestation interdite
alors que nous sommes en plein état
d'urgence ces voyous ses ennemis de la
république ont saccagé le mémorial
improvisé
situé en plein coeur de paris place de
la république
alors que les obsèques des victimes des
attentats ne sont pas encore terminés
l'abject a eu lieu c'est un affront
insupportable fait aux victimes et au
peuple de france qui ne peuvent plus
accepter que l'état soit défaillant j'ai
honte de ce qui s'est passé j'ai honte
en pensant aux victimes en pensant à nos
compatriotes refonder mans choqué par
les attentats du 7 et 9 janvier
du 26 juin et du 13 novembre
317 interpellation 174 garde à vue dont
neuf prolongé une fois de plus la
réaction a eu lieu mais après gouverner
c'est prévoir
l'autorité ne se paye pas de mots mais
d'actes
quand on est en guerre on doit d'abord
et surtout s'occuper de la protection
des français
monsieur le premier ministre dans le
contexte où nous sommes
comment pouvez-vous justifier cette
faute grave de l'état
merci la ta parole est au ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le député cochet
l'autorité l'outrance l'énervement ne
sont pas des notions qui se superposent
les unes aux autres
l'autorité c'est de prendre des
décisions claires et de les assumer nous
avons pris des décisions claires dans le
cadre de l'état d'urgence
je veux les rappeler ici nous avons
interdit les manifestations
et j'ai donné instruction au préfet
parce qu'il ya une grande conférence
internationale qui a mobilisé depuis des
mois la société civile que l'on puisse
dans le cadre d'un dialogue avec les
organisations non gouvernementales et
les associations pacifistes permette non
pas des manifestations des déambulations
mais des rassemblements pacifiques
il y en a eu 60 pendant le week-end
auquel ont participé des militants
d'organisations gouvernement
gouvernementales et des militants
écologistes pacifique qui se sont bien
passées et place de la république
il y a eu un rassemblement pacifique il
ya une chaîne humaine pacifique qui
s'est bien passé et puis un groupe de
casseurs dans l'irrespect total de la
mémoire de ceux qui ont perdu la vie à
l'occasion des attentats ont joué avec
une extrême violence
un jeu qui doit être condamné avec la
plus grande fermeté que j'ai condamné
avec la plus grande fermeté et qui a
conduit les forces de l'ordre
contrairement à ce que vous dites à
intervenir courageusement et
immédiatement pour mettre hors d'état de
nuire ces individus qui ont été sous
l'autorité du procureur de la république
placé en garde à vue et l'autorité de
l'état c'est dans le respect du droit et
sous l'autorité du procureur de la
république de faire passer le droit ce
n'est pas l'énervement ce n'est pas
l'outrance ce n'est pas les accusations
sans fondement qui ont présidé à votre
question
voilà ce qui s'est passé exactement et
préalablement à cette manifestation
j'avais
prix 26 assignation résistance n'ont pas
de militants écologistes mais de
casseurs nous avions pris toutes les
précautions
nous avons été fermes et nous le ferons
merci pour le groupe social